では お釈迦様のことば
セーコーパタウィングディジェッサティーヤマローカッンチャイマンサデーバカンセーコーダンマパダンサドゥデーシタンクサラロープッカミワパチェッサティー
あまり難しくない ただ一言葉入っただけ
成功という 成功という人がこの世の中制覇しますよと
ヤマローカも神々の世界も全部入って一切の生命を司るんだよと
成功 成功という人がこの見事に語っているこの真理の言葉を花咲かせて見せるんだと
だから成功という一言葉勉強すればそれで終わり
成功ってどんな意味でしょうかね
学ぶ人  成功っていうのは
学ぶ人  それで言えばわかったような気がしますね
それが一番危ないところで
皆様と我々の勉強の違うところはそこら辺にあります
我々はこのわかったような気がすることはものすごい危険に思うんです
私たちの小さい頃 それだけ言っておいたんで
先生たちは それだけは気をつけなさいと
何も勉強できなくなるんだと
あ そうかということ 今もう私と喋ってる人々ではないけど
あ そうかって言っちゃうと
まあまあはい やめましたと
話は それがすごい危険です
学んだことじゃないんです
あ そうか そうかということは
自分の今まで考えていた考え方でしょうに
思考開発してないんです
で 学ぶ人っていうのは
やっぱりこの 今までの思考を変えて
妄想の世界を変えて ありのままの真理見てみようではないかと
根本的ところからもう思考を変えていくんです
ああ そうか 清少納言にも書いているんだ
あの本にも書いているんだ
あちらも書いているんだとか
それだったらもうわからなくなっちゃうんです
私は知ってるんだっていう意味だからね
随分この成功の世界っていうのは
学ぶ人の世界とは違うんです
今までの考え方 思考 あれこれとか
固定概念っていうのはね
これは一つも真理ではございません
真理であったならば 見事に世界制覇しているはずなんです
生命として乗り越えているはずなんです
苦しみを乗り越えているはずなんです
何を勉強しても 何を考えたっても
人間はどんどん堕落するんであって
発展することっていうのは全然ないでしょうに
では 学問発展して人間成功したんですかね
堕落しただけでしょう
科学発展して人類は偉大なる幸福を味わってますかね
偉大なる不幸にはなっていることだけは確かなんです
では 昔の人々にあったという苦しみが何か消してるんですかね
今は 昔の人は病気になったら可哀想で手術もできなくて
レントゲンもなくて死んでしまったと
今はどうですか？レントゲンあるんだから同じことでしょうに
今も泣きながらワニ見に行かながら死んでいくでしょうに
癌になったら何か治療法はある？ただ体をクタクタいじるだけで
今も治療法ないんですよ
癌だけじゃなくて風邪にも
昔もなかったんです そんな大して変わってないんです
今飛行機があるんだからといって
人間の問題はそのまま
というか 問題あるということに気づく暇もなくなっている
面白いことで 昔の人間には暇があった
余裕がありました だから人生っていうのは大変苦しいなと
余裕があるんだったら遊べばいいのに
そういう人々は遊びながら
もう人生っていうのは苦しいものやと考える暇があったんです
今それさえない それすごい経済的に発展しているというんです
時間仕事をしなきゃ食えないのに
法律だけはあるんですけどね
一日の労働時間これだけだよとかね
その労働時間だけ仕事しちゃえば
もう会社が成り立たないそうです
サービス作業も三業もしなくちゃいけないんです
それって立派な会社ですかね
そういう人々はのんびり生きている人々にはアドバイスまでするんです
あんた方は貧乏なのはそういう性格だからやと
誰も聞いてあげないんですけどね
こちらから専門家が言ったとしても
だから私は言いたいのは
このどんな知識が発展したっても
結局人間はどんどん不幸になるだけで
科学発展のおかげで吸う呼吸もなくなったという
ものすごいありがたい話で
飲む水も消えてしまったと
食べる食べ物にも毒が入ってしまったと
売るかものは売るんですよ
だから昔の米だったら香りがありました
味がありました 今は香りがあると食べないんですね
人工的なものでなきゃ
自然なものだったら食べない
それでいっぱい 我々は毒いっぱい入っているものを食べているんだと
面白いことというのは
リンゴはどれほど香りがあるのかと
わからないでしょう もう本当に自然のリンゴ１個この部屋にあったら
部屋中もう香りが漂うんですよ
かなり強烈です これはいやいや人工的でなきゃということで香りを殺す
すごい発展だというんです
それには 肉体は自然なものだから
自然なリンゴだったら １
日リンゴ１個食べれば医者は要らんという言葉さがあるみたいんですよ
今のリンゴだったら １
日リンゴ１個食べるんだったら
必ず医者に電話をかけておけということを言わなくちゃいけないんです
ご飯もそうで 他の野菜もそうです
それは科学発展のおかげです
だから このまあ 生きづらい世界
貧しい人々に何かあげられない時代
飢え死になる時代を作っただけ
そういうことで 我々の思考パターンでは決して人間の苦しみを決してないんです
心に余裕が与えてくれてないんです
精神的な安定を作ってくれてないんです
戦いはやめてないんです
弱い者いじめは未だにやめてないんです
科学 学問 発展すればするほど
弱い者いじめ 新しい研究開発なんかすると
とにかく貧しい人々はやっつけてやるぞという考え方でやっているんです
あなた方にあげませんよと
これはもう 10万円ですよと
このお薬はと いうと  10年間仕事をしても 10万円の収入のない人々はもう遮断する
まあ結局はそんなもんで
だから我々の思考 素晴らしいんだ
立派だ 分かってるんだ
そんなことはという態度では分からないんです
だから学ぶ人っていうのはそうではなくて
自分を改革するんです
ワンパターンではやらないんです
かなり革命的でないとできないんです
かなり大胆でないと学ぶ人にはなりません
過去のシステムを壊していかないと
過去のシステムというのはもう思考パターンなんです
それで学ぶことっていうのは
仏教ではアディシーラ
アディチッタ アディパンニャーという３つに分けてます
シーラっていうのは戒律
道徳なんです 道徳を守ること自体もものすごい改革的で革命的で
結構大胆なことなんです
ちっぽけな道徳ではダメなんです
私は 私はあまり人に目をかけませんよとかね
そんなのはシーラには入りません
なぜかというと 私は人に目をかけませんと
それが迷惑だということだからね
ジャイナ教の非暴力主義みたいに
で 例えば戒律の場合は
殺生するなよということ
殺生したいっていうのは人間の普遍的な気持ちなんですね
自分も人間なんです だから殺生したいという気持ちが必ずあるはずなんです
それはないというんだから
もう学ぶ人になりません
いつでも仏教では殺生しないとか言った途端
そんなのは当たり前 分かっているんだということになるんです
当たり前 分かっている
なんだ面白くない話だと
聞き飽きてるんだという気分になるんです
ということは もう学ぶ人ではありません
殺生するなよと言ったら
その中ですごい考え方があるんです
自分が何者かと発見しなくちゃいけない
自分が本当は殺生する者なんです
それ自分だけじゃないんです
一切の生命はみんな殺生するものなんですよ
みんな殺生する世界で殺生しないということは
もう革命的な精神がないと
大胆な精神がないと すべて破って前に進む人でないとできるわけじゃないんです
それが正しい殺生しないという解決なんです
だからこのサッレーク・スッタという経典がありまして
その経典は その道徳の世界というのはすごい明確に道徳を守る守り方を説明しているんです
他の人々は殺生している
だからこそ私は殺生しないように励む
努むと 私にチャレンジする目的がある
頑張るために 努力するために
ちゃんとした訳があるということで
どんなわけかというと
誰でも殺生する それで私はチャレンジする
殺生しないことを 誰でも殺生するというのは自分も殺生する
生命たるものは誰でも嘘をつく
そこで私はチャレンジするんだぞと
嘘つかんぞという戦いでなきゃ
生命に打ち勝ったことになりません
だから コー・イマン・パタ・ウィン
誰が勝つのかと 山の世界であろうが
神々もとも一切の生命に打ち勝って勝利者は誰ですかというと
この一番目にシーラが入ってくるんです
その場合はアディ・シーラという言葉があるんですよ
アディっていうのは この英語の単語を借りて言えばスーパーというスーパー
レベルが高いというね
あのスーパーマーケットのあれが単語の意味間違ってるんです
スーパーマーケットといえば
なんかもう安いものばっかり売ってる感じがするでしょ
デパートじゃないんだから
スーパーマーケットっていうのはもうマーケットという
まあただ店なんですね
これはすごい普通の店で
八百屋さんがいて 魚屋さんがいて
米を売っているところがあったりとかね
それで昔は小さな小さなマーケットいっぱいあって
それで商店街に行って
こちらから魚買って あちらからキャベツを買って
こちらからジャガイモを買ってとかね
それで自分の袋に全部入れて家に持っていく
それが一箇所にまとめたんだから
スーパーマーケットというだけ
すごいマーケットだと
何でもあると という意味でスーパーマーケットなんです
[背景音楽]服も買えるんだと
魚買って 前はそうではなかったんだからね
魚屋さんに行って もうなんとかちょっとこれこれ置いてくださいと言って頼んで
服も買わなくちゃいけない
服屋さんに行かなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると分で もうなんていう買い物できないんですよ
それがなくなったんだから
すごいマーケットっていう意味でスーパーマーケットという言葉も使ってますが
一応スーパーっていうのはすごいという意味なんです
普通じゃないと そういうことでアディシーラ
普通の戒律 道徳っていう意味じゃないんです
こんな普通の誰にでもできるレベルではダメだっていうことで
すごい超人的にやらなくちゃいけないっていうことです
そこでアディシーラやっただけでも
もう人間の世界を乗り越えてますよもう
尋常な人間じゃないんです
みんなやってるのにやってないんだから
みんな嘘ついてるのに
この人は嘘つかないんだから
だから仲間やってることやってないんです
飛び出しているんです
だから日本文化で考えちゃうと無理ですね
仏教は だからもうはっきり言いますけど
我々インド系の連中はすごい怠け者って言うでしょ
本当は皆様方なんです
あれが怠け思考なんですよ
食いために朝から晩まで頑張るかもしれませんだけど
我々は１時間頑張ればなんとか食べるでしょ
それでいいやということでいい加減にするんです
私たちは こちらそうじゃないんです
１日頑張らなきゃってこと
そこで頑張ってるんだと思っても
結局は文化はみんなやる
みんなやることはやる文化なんです
質問があったら聞いてくださいと周り見るんです
気持ち悪いと 周りは関係ないでしょうに
自分に質問があれば聞けばいいでしょうに
聞かないんです だってこの人質問してないんだから
やっぱりまずいと これは
あれって何？だからみんなやってることやっちゃえば安全だ
怪我しないんだ という考え方です
出る国は何でしたっけ？撃たれるという言葉様で作っている
だからいつでもそのまんまで
これ怠けでしょ ブッダは出てなさいと
撃たれても負けるかと
そんなのは馬鹿やと このレベルから出て行けと
飛び出せと 乗り越えなさいと
だから仏教の場合は この怠けという単語はものすごい強烈に出てくるのです
それは心理学的なことなんです
怠けと精進というのは
何でしたっけ アーラッダヴィリヤッサーヤンダンモ
この教えはアーラッダヴィリヤ
徹底的に精進する人のためにあるんです
ナーヤンダンモ クティ
クシータサ 怠け者には無理ということでカットするんです
ブッダの道はもう生命の次元を乗り越えて飛び出そう教えなんです
だったら怠け者には無理やと
出る国は打たれるぞという言葉責めにハメられちゃうと
もうもうもう関係なくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの戒律ということにしたって
道徳世界ですけど すごいもうアディというスーパーというレベルでやらなくちゃいけないと
2番目はアディチッタ
心 心をなんとか育てるとか
なんとかとか 俗世間でもありますけど
そんな程度では程度では足らんと
だから世の中の人々はみんな興奮主義者で
混乱でわいわいきゃーきゃーきゃーきゃーと言いながら生きている
たとえ学者の集まりであろうとも
ものすごい興奮真っ最中なレベルなんですね
喋るは喋るは食べるは飲むは
もう学会なんかはもう喋ってる内容は違うかもしれませんだけど
普通の人々を集めて喋ってることとそれほど変わりがないんですよ
もう ただ自分たちの研究のことをこれはこれ
我々はというだけの話で
キャーキャーキャーキャーキャーキャーものすごい興奮状態で混乱状態
だから生命たるものはみんな興奮主義者で混乱状態でいると
それで私がだからこそ徹底的に落ち着いているんだと
ということで落ち着きを育てるとな
集中力ですね サマーディということですね
アディチッタっていうのは
今思い出したんですけど
その考え方はなんかすごいもう怠け者たちが誤解する時まだあるんですよ
ただ単にもう社会から自分が離れて怠け者ですよ
社会と一緒にいろんなことをやらなくちゃいかんからね
それで私はそういう興味ない
みんなやってるんだけどとかね
みんな一生懸命いろんなことを頑張ってやっているのに
自分が手を組んで他の興味ないと
なんかえらい仏教徒のふりをするんです
それは違います ただの怠け者なんです
このシステムそのものを乗り越えるんだから
ものすごい力ある人ですよ
興味ない 関わりがないという場合は
怠け者にも言えるんだよ
私は全然興味がない 関わりを持ちたくないということを怠け者にも言える
だからそこら辺気をつけてこの区別しておかないと
だから心を統一することもそういうことで
このもう大体統一するときはそういう問題が出てくるのは
自分が私はそういう社会は嫌とかね
そういう興奮しているガチャガチャ嫌とかね
言って自分から怠けてるだけで
だから世界中みんな興奮主義者でいたっても
そこで落ち着いている
というすごい精神なんです
で 番目はパンニャー チエーで
で チエーっていう場合もアディパンニャーなんです
アディパンニャーにチャレンジするんです
これが説明やめた方がいいと思います
アディパンニャーって何なのかと
アディパンニャーは難しいんだから
お釈迦様はそこをそういうところではちゃんとこれがパンニャーであるということは
一応すごい親切にアドバイスするんです
そのアドバイスなく説明しちゃうと
これは真理不可能ということになります
だから このただもう地球が丸いとかね
それぐらいは誰にも言えるんですよ
そんな知識ではもう超越した知識にはなりません
まあ最低もうほんのちっぽけな方程式発見した
アインシュタインの相対論
相対論みたいにね それぐらいでも見てもらわないと
世界ではすごい頭がいいと言わないでしょうに
僕らから見れば あんなのは何やと
アインシュタインの相対論なんかはと
という態度なんです もっと真理はもっともっと深いところにあるんじゃないかと
そう考えちゃうと 人間には無理不可能になるんです
アインシュタインはそこら中にたくさんいるわけじゃないんだからね
そんな程度の人間は だからお釈迦様がこの本当の智慧っていうのはありのままに見ることであると
それで あなた方は一切は無常であるということを発見しなさいと
一切は瞬間だけ現れてくる
ほんのわずかな現象であって
すぐ消えてしまいますよと
それが発見しなさい それがすごい真理ですと
それは究極の真理ですと
それ以外は何もなしと
それはパンニャーに対する答えなんですね
それがないと我々人間にはできません
ブッダのレベルの智慧がないと
能力がないと発見できません
だからパンニャーの場合だけは
すごい安くアドバイスということ
いわゆる返事 答えですね
答えは出しておく そうすると
そんな単純なことかと思うんですよ
なんだブッダの教えって面白くないと
もっとすごいことだと思ったんだよと
そういう風に思うんだから
そこでまたごちゃごちゃなところになっちゃいます
それはすごい教えなんです
なぜかというと アディパンニャーが現れたら
一切無常であるとわかったら
もう証拠者なんです もう何にもとらわれない人間になっているんです
そうなってないんだから
知るっていうこと 知ったっていうことにならないんです
それぐらいの話 成功っていうのは
そういう風に学ぶ人 学ぶっていうことはすごい大変なことで
自分を改良していかなくちゃいけない
日々自分が変わって変わって
上へ上へ上へ上へといかなくちゃいかないんです
別な言葉に変えて言えば
みんなやっていることはやらないことなんです
みんなやっているんだからという理屈を持ってくると
だからやるのよというのはブッダの半分
次の半分なんです 我々の場合はみんなやっているんだからやりましょうということでしょう
それをお釈迦様 みんなやっているんだからやらないよと
みんなやっていることをやっちゃうとみんなと一緒でしょうに
みんなに勝ったわけじゃないでしょうに
だから誰が勝つのかというと
そういう成功が勝ちますよ
他の人に勝てませんよという答えになるんです
ぴったしの答えなんです
学ぶ人は勝ちますよと
お話は以上です